We next discuss
interventions suggested
by the model developed for
the Framingham Heart Study.
The first intervention
has to do with drugs
to lower blood pressure.
In FDR's time,
hypertension drugs
were too toxic
for practical use.
But in the 1950s, the diuretic
chlorothiazide was developed,
and the Framingham Heart
Study gave Ed Freis
the evidence needed to argue
for testing effects for blood
pressure drugs.
In fact, the Veterans
Administration Trial
was conducted.
This was a randomized,
double blind clinical trial,
that found decreased risk
of coronary heart disease.
Now, the market for
diuretics worldwide
is more than a billion dollars.
Another intervention had to do
with-- to lower cholesterol.
Despite the Framingham results,
early cholesterol drugs
were too toxic
for practical use.
But in the 1970s, the first
statins were developed.
The study of 4,444
patients with CHD
revealed that statins
cause a 37% risk
reduction of a
second heart attack.
Furthermore, a study of 6,595
men with high cholesterol
revealed that statins cause a
32% risk reduction in deaths.
Now, the market for
statins worldwide
is more than $20 billion.